so it has been quite a season for you on
season 3 of walking dead how did you
keep it secret and what are you gonna
miss most about the show
I kept it secret by lying to lots of
people at San Diego comic-con yesterday
I counted about 87 interviews where I
just boldface lied to the press
although that shouldn't be surprising I
live for a living so maybe maybe that's
not something anyone should hold against
me I was surprised actually we were able
to keep it under wraps
I didn't think we guy found out and I
think April and we shot it in June and
to keep it a secret all the way until
November was something I didn't think we
could do like frankly I presume
AMC buried a few bodies I think they had
some snipers involved I'm not sure hey
you know I miss the people it's I've
never worked with a group of people that
dedicated and that courageous and that
close as a family especially those of us
from season one
really really got quite close and saying
goodbye to Andy and to Chandler and
stuff like that and Norman Steven it was
difficult but then again you know a job
that great only comes along once every
now and again so just grateful for it
when you got it what was it now you
mentioned and Julian cocoa say your
on-screen husband wasn't like working
with him and and what was it like that
final scene that he had to record - I
heard that he didn't want you on on set
while he was recording the news where he
found out that Laurie darling yes I had
Andy and I are there for each other a
lot off-camera and we're good friends
our families are good friends
and on this one he asked that I be sort
of nowhere near so I was back at the
trailers and I could hear him I don't
think they I don't think they used the
tapes but there were certain takes where
he was just screaming mad and um I could
hear him all the way it was like my half
a kilometer away
um he's a dream to work with
I mean he really is you know what's
amazing about Andy you might not know
he's English which is sort of
extraordinary he stayed in his accent
for so much of the first season that our
crew when he finally addressed the crew
the very last day to thank everyone they
thought he was putting on the English
accent and
but he's a dream he's one of the most
professional and brave actors I've ever
known
of course you both had very big things
to mention Andes they're your death
scene as well what was it like acting
mad you know the preparation was really
just the three seasons that went before
it
there wasn't we didn't rehearse much of
it we didn't we didn't talk too much
about it
I mean Chandler and I go back to the
pilot together and watching him grow
from a little boy into this incredible
young man really was such an honor to be
around therefore and saying goodbye to
each other was enormously difficult so
we just we just sort of left it all on
film and you know did our thing how do
you think your own screen husband's
gonna be coping with two kids now by
himself in the apocalypse well I'll tell
you Andy's real-life wife is such an
absolute rockstar of a mom that he would
be lost without her I don't know if he
will be equally lost without Laurie but
um I you know I think Rick has has
demonstrated that he's a man with you
know pretty extraordinary vicissitudes
but he does seem to come out on top so I
think the kids are in good hands
what did you enjoy most about the three
seasons that we've seen you on a screen
in Walking Dead and how do you think you
get on with Laurie if you met her in
real life if she existed I would love
Laurie I I adore her I never quite
understood the camp of people who've got
problems with her but for what I from
what I can tell from talking to people
very few of them are women um I think
she's a powerhouse and
I don't think she apologizes for her
decisions she's made mistakes as
everybody has but I have an enormous
amount of respect for the heart with
which she lives her life I've learned
I'm a better actor for having worked
with Andy and Norman and John and and
Jeff and Steven and Scott Wilson and all
these amazing people I'm a better actor
and maybe a better person about
memorable shooting days for you they're
kind of moments erased and that for you
as well Oh
I mean it's so hot that your brain sort
of bubbles away parts of the memories of
things I mean I have memories of
literally hearing your skin cooking um
but you know most of the memories I have
between action and cut are of us
laughing Steven Yeun is one of the
funniest people alive and every now and
again
he'll just sort of look at you and
just end up busting a gut and it's we
had we had an enormous amount of fun
shooting the show even though it doesn't
really look like it
welcome unit forwards to coming at for
me now Sarah uh well I am continuing my
litany of British leading man I did a
movie with Richard Armitage who is black
sky yes and he's a just a lovely lovely
man we had a wonderful time working
together that movies coming out I think
is sometime in the next year and I just
died just finished a play so that was
good fun and got to get back to theater
a little and let's see what comes next
you